I'm William V Phillips bull Phillips I
want a Nobel Prize in 1997 Nobel Prize
in Physics and I make gases of atoms are
really really cold time is one of the
most important things we measure in
modern life not to find our way to
appointments but to navigate through the
Global Positioning System for high-speed
synchronous communication we really
precise timing and the best kinds of
clocks for doing that timing our atomic
clocks so every clock has some sort of a
ticker a grandfather's clock has a
pendulum that swings back and forth of
course watch has a vibrating quartz
crystal the best tickers are atoms and
the reason they're the best tickers of
are that the ticking frequency is very
little affected by outside influences
and the other key thing is that all
atoms are the same kind to get exactly
the same rate whereas every pendulum is
a little different every quartz crystal
is a little different every atom is
absolutely identical I've troubled
atomic HAWX is the atoms are moving
really fast so what we did was learn how
to use laser light to push on the ABS in
such a way as to make them slow down and
when they're really slow then you can
measure their ticking frequencies better
and we got down to temperatures using
laser cooling below one millionth of
degree above absolute zero at room
temperature we're at about 300 degrees
above absolute zero and the coldest
natural temperature in the universe the
blackbody radiation left over from the
Big Bang is about three degrees above
absolute zero
we're going to less than a millionth of
a degree above absolute zero and the
atoms are moving at less than a
centimetre per second with that you can
make incredibly good atomic clocks so by
using laser coins we've been able to
revolutionize time
keeping
we all want
that our food is safe but doing that can
be really hard looking for contaminants
in raw materials is tough the statistics
are stacked against us today we can only
test for pathogens individually one
sample at a time and that means hundreds
if not thousands of tests most of which
deliver a simple negative result we
needed to think about this differently
that's why Mars that IBM joined forces
to sequence the genomes of all the
organisms in the food supply chain
that's millions of organisms but big
data is what IBM is good at the DNA and
RNA sequences show you all the harmless
bacteria that are found in normal safe
food if we do the test and the
microorganisms are suddenly different
something's up the organisms have
changed because the environment has
changed it could be contaminated and not
only that this tells us things that we
never could have seen before like where
the food was grown how it was
transported and maybe even what happened
on route our approach to food safety
just got a lot smarter